[Music]
[Music]
hey guys as you can tell by the title
itself in this video i'm bringing you
the second part of everything we know
about the season 8 premiere
based on teasers trailers and a few
official spoilers
in part one i brought you the actual
footage from episode 1 in which we can
see the new game of thrones intro
the ice floor spreads out from the wall
representing the night king and his army
who brings the storm in winter and goes
to the lost heart
the seat of house summer this basically
confirms that the night king will in the
first episode attack last heart and
destroy it
in part 1 i also brought you the reports
on reporters who attended the exclusive
premiere
which revealed the many main events of
the premiere including a spoiler of john
snow learning the truth about his
parents in that very episode
we also discussed opening scene as well
as many reunions in the great meeting
that will take place at winterfell
most of the main characters will attend
that huge urgent meeting that'll be
called upon by john snow when bran tells
him that the ball has fallen
to discuss their strategy and defenses
against the night king
let's continue with the meeting i
believe jaime is in winterfell here and
brienne is worried for how danny
targaryen the person he tried to kill
and brain stark also the person he tried
to kill will react to it
from the new teasers we also know tyrion
will attend these meetings as well
which again is not coming as a surprise
as it was expected the north nurse will
not accept danny as good as john did
it has been officially confirmed for
quite a long time that sense and danny
will have a very tense first meeting
and it's also been recently confirmed
that other northern lords will side with
sansa
and share the same feelings towards the
dragon queen the north nurse will need
some more convincing to trust dany
according to bella ramsey her character
liana mormont is not very happy with the
arrival of a foreign queen
so it's not only sansa who gives some
hard time to john over dany
but it's also the other northern lords
and ladies as well and this right here
is the first meeting summoned by jon
snow upon their arrival at winterfell
since the north nerds did not accept
danny very well tyrion is pretty much
saying they might not like each other
but they must fight together nonetheless
or otherwise they will all die
this speech should bring the northerners
to their senses besides talking about
dany in this huge meeting at minerfeld
they will also discuss their defenses
one of the first orders from this
meeting will go to the blacksmiths with
gendry on its head
make all weapons shields and no defenses
out of dragonglass
here we have our favorite blacksmith
either forging weapons out of
journalists or even trying to forge
brand new valyrian steel swords now that
they have both
journalists and dragonfire in which many
believe lies the secret to forging
valyrian steel
one or the other the two are the only
substances capable of killing vice
vokers and their whites
and they need it now more than ever with
the dead coming for them
as we saw from the seasoning these are
the unsullied will have their shields
upgraded
with dragonglass edges vannerfeld now
has a dark trench all around it and
everyone wields dragonless weapons with
sitherian the winner velvet box is full
of journalists next to him
and the journalist is actually being
added to shiloh de frieze which is a
defensive anti-cavalry measure
john meant to dragonstone not only to
meet the dragon queen but also to mind
dragonglass
with john and dany's arrival at
winterfell of course they brought
junglers from dragonstone to use it in
the war to come
and therefore their armies carrying the
journalists made weapons does not come
as a surprise
as i already said journalist is the key
to defeating the white walkers
so the living will have to use it in
every way possible as confirmed by
reporters who attended the season 8
exclusive premiere
john will also in this episode learn of
his shoe parentage
an actor who plays sam tease this about
his character in season 8.
sam is really feeling the responsibility
of this information but he knows john
would rather hear this from sam than
anybody else
in my opinion this is a confirmation
that sam will be the one to reveal john
the truth
simon brand discovered together the
truth but sam would probably be a better
messenger
given bran's detachment from his family
and weird behavior ever since he became
the three-eighth raven
here i assume bran says to sam that it's
better if he's the one to tell john the
truth
and sam tries to figure out the best way
to deliver such information
let's get back to reunions because after
all this episode will be marked by them
john and dany are the only two who
arrive at winterfell there's plenty of
characters and therefore many more
unions
there's also center the huncle gaine who
is a part of jon's crew
he will reunite with perhaps the only
two people he cares in this world
sans and arya there's also genji and
darya reunion
which could potentially be the first
step forward into geiger's fighters
robert baratheon's promise tori's father
ned stark in season 1 finally being
fulfilled
i also think that tarya's line from the
trailer where she says i know death has
got many faces
is coming from her conversation with
genji next we have tirion and sansa
once a married couple the two will
definitely be happy to save on another
alignment well after a long time
tyrion was the only lannister that cared
for sansa and actually tried to make her
time at king's landing a bit better
by keeping her safe from king joffrey
numerous times and by being kind to her
all the time
it did not take sense that too long to
realize that tyrion is not like his
family
she quickly grew to trust him and like
him as a person
they've both been through some rough
times since then and one or two scenes
between these two would be great to see
if i'd have to guess i'd say that here
in the last sensa how she escaped king's
landing
and have they managed to see through
littlefinger's game while we're all
excited for the bigger unions there's
plenty of let's call it minor reunions
that are also going to be very
interesting
such as your mormont reuniting williana
mormont and sam
so basically what happens in the north
in the season 8 premiere is the night
king destroying lost heart
while winterfell faces many iranians and
first dance meeting
bannerfell is also under preparation for
the great war john most likely learns
the truth from sam and brain
and impossibly rides a dragon these
shots might also be from the season 8
premiere
which means that dany might teach jon
how to ride the dragon
in the trailer we see jon and danny
approaching drogon and rhaegal
and here they are probably flying them
above wienerfell and this is reaction of
various davos centerians seeing it
keep it in mind that all these three
have already seen dragons above their
heads quite a lot of times
so the only reason they'd look at a
dragon with a bit of shock would be
seeing johnston riding dany's other
dragon regal
a dragon named after jon's father egger
targaryen
it would be very cool to see jon riding
a dragon in the season 8 premiere
especially if dany's pregnant and
therefore will not be able to ride her
dragon later on in the season
leaving it to john to use them as best
as possible down style thinking is
landing urine will arrive at the golden
company
as seen in the trailer euron's iron
fleet is filled with the golden company
that is coming to help cersei retrieve
seven kingdoms under her rule
and here cersei likely oversees their
rival we also got to see cersei having a
meeting with euron greyjoy and the
leader of the golden company harry
strickland
which should also take place in the
first episode although i doubt we'll see
more than that of them
by them i mean harry and urine there
will probably be a few more scenes of
cersei
the premiere will also probably provide
a closure of theon's rescue mission
even though some of you might not have
caught it the official trailer shoved
the syrian as well as theon greyjoy
we saw a glimpse of john greyjoy along
with harry strickland the leader of the
gunning company in the great hall of the
red cape in king's landing
in depth analysis also revealed two
different set of greyjoy fleets with
different crack and painted sails
one belonging to urine on which yarn in
the rr and the other fleet belonging to
yara on which theon is
trying to catch up to urine and save his
sister the difference between yara's and
euron's fleets is that eurons has a
third red eye inscribed onto the head of
the kraken
i also found one more difference and
it's in the fact that the shape of the
sails are different as well
yara favors square eggs while you're on
outside his own terrifying gaelis
silence
prefers support ships that employ
triangular 4 and
aft rigging here we see the silence here
on slongship returning to westeros
alongside the rest of euron's fleet in
the background loaded at the division of
the golden company and their commander
harry strickland
and here we see a shot of the grayjay
fleet and since it contains square
right's type of sails and more
importantly since there is no red eye on
the kraken
we can tell for a fact that it's yara's
fleet commanded by theon greyjoy
in the season 7 finale theon finally
earned the respect of the ironborn
and rallied the r's remaining supporters
to rescue yara and here he is in season
8
searching for euron's fleet in my
opinion theon will save yara while urine
is having a meeting with cersei and
harry
it's possible that tiara will not be
yara anymore much like theon was not
theon for a long time since ramsay
tortured him
it's highly possible that you're
untortured yara and since we all know
how euron tortures his prisoners in the
show and in the books
it's likely that tara lost her tongue
however i do believe that theon will
save yara and get her back
and the two will then sail north to help
jon snow and danny defend winterfell
as for yearn he will arrive at king's
landing with the golden company in the
season 8 premiere
he will then have a meeting with cersei
and he will probably demand the wedding
as it was confirmed by the official
thesis general blackmail serves saint of
getting what he wants
a marriage and he will therefore become
the king here's the shot of cersei
lannister
evelina harry who plays search that has
to say is more than interesting
lina says as usual with cersei she is
trapped in a web of her own making so
what's the nature of this web
lena harry did not give any details but
looking on euron's photo and what he's
got to say about his season 8 pets
it's more than obvious that lena is
talking about cersei being trapped in
neuron's hands
after she so foolishly let urine make a
contract with the golden company
and making him so powerful overall by
westback euron said this
euron wants to become the king of the
seven kingdoms yet he is also
blackmailing cersei
uranus blackmailing starts saving the
golden company and his arnold fleet
cersei's got to marry him or he will
leave it his fleet and turn the golem
company against her
as it might be cersei who paid them but
it's yearn who made a deal with them
and it's yearn whose name is on the
contract that's why cersei is trapped in
a web of her own making
and that's how euron is blackmailing her
wouldn't be surprised if cersei is
forced to marry euron in the very first
episode
okay guys that will be everything we
know about the season a premiere
supportive with all the trailers teasers
and a few spoilers
how do you like the first episode of the
final season and what do you think will
also take place
please make sure to let me know in the
comment section down below and as always
i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our channel and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace